kristen fisher is live outside of the
hospital there in bethesda maryland
kristen a lot to take in and an update
from the doctors as well
yes sandra well over the last few hours
there's been a great deal of confusion
over how
exactly president trump is doing it
started
with that briefing earlier today from
the president's doctor
and his medical team here at walter reed
but then we got this statement from a
senior administration official somebody
very close
to president trump who said something
not totally opposite but very close it
made it sound that president trump was
in
a much more serious state than the
doctors led us to believe
during that briefing well since then we
have been working our sources working
the phones and our john roberts was able
to get in touch
with a senior administration official
who really tried to clarify
exactly what was meant in that statement
and i want to read it to you in full
the senior administration official says
that quote 24 hours ago there was real
concern
about the president's vitals for the
past 12 hours there has been zero
concern
early indications are for an extremely
good prognosis but the next
48 hours will be critical now compare
that
to what the president's doctor dr sean
connelly
said just earlier today this morning the
president
is doing very well the team and i are
extremely happy with the progress the
president has made
thursday he had a mild cough and some
nasal congestion and fatigue
all of which are now resolving and
improving
now when you are dealing with something
as sensitive as the health and
well-being of the president of the
united states the entire world
is watching and so it is absolutely
essential that the white house and the
president's medical team
are unified in the statements that they
are giving to the press
and to the public clearly they have some
work to do on that front
a little bit more detail as to how we
got
to this point according to this senior
administration official
president trump was showing troubling
signs of a possible progression from
mild to a more severe case of covid19
that's when medical professionals took
quick action to aggressively
intervene they made that decision to
bring president trump here
out of an abundance of caution and so
far the president
seems to be responding well to the
treatment
that they have been giving him and you
know it was so
concerning yesterday when president
trump we all know loves to tweet
wasn't tweeting at all or hardly at all
so today though we've gotten a few
tweets from president trump including
this one
just about an hour ago he tweeted quote
our great usa
wants and needs stimulus work together
and get it done thank you so there you
have
a tweet from the president that sounds
certainly
a lot more like the president that we
all know so well he tweeted earlier
today that
he's feeling very well and so now we
just wait and see sandra because now we
have multiple people telling us
and we know just from what we know about
covid19 that these next 48 hours truly
are going to be critical
so the entire media there's now dozens
of members of the media from all over
the world here there are people here you
can hear them honking their horns
lots of trump flags right outside walter
reed
this is truly going to be a bit of a
circus for the next few days
while president trump stays here and
tries to get better sandra kristen thank
you